so Jairo on there glad to be here today
today we are going to talk about Ibis
which is a pretty cool Python library
that can help you to transition from
single openness code to distributed data
frames so very important this legal
disclaimer basically saying we're not
giving financial devices and that should
be pretty obvious so tell your audience
why should you be interested so if you
like pandas but want to analyze large
data set or maybe your interesting
distributed data frames but you don't
know which one to pick because there's
so many these days or maybe you want to
just write your code once and have it
run faster and more scalable without
making code changes if any of these
seems relevant to you this is this is a
talk for you before we start just a
quick introduction my name is Li Jing
I'm a software engineer working at 2
Sigma and we are we working on modeling
tools team which which would be
platforms using open source technologies
I've been mostly a working on a lot of
open source projects my my work include
working on Apache spark and I I guess
that's pretty should be pretty familiar
to most of people here
Apache arrow as is open source library
that that is that delivers high
performance in column a high performance
a memory data format and flink as a
time-series library on top of apache
spark and today we're going to talk
about Ibis and this is my kanji everyone
my name is han ji I'm also software
engineer at 2 Sigma and I work with Lee
and mostly focused on building at
distributed computing capabilities and
using open source tools like Apache so
its TARDIS Hawk I want to start a talk
with a common data science task this is
some pennis code and it should be pretty
familiar to tennis users here we're just
doing three very basic things
first thing we're doing we're just
taking two columns take the average and
assign it to a new column the second
line here we are actually performing a
group by rolling operation which just
takes we're goodbye key and take a three
a three row rolling window computer me
and design to a new column called
feature two and lastly we're just doing
a pretty straightforward
goodbye aggregation so this code is
pretty straightforward we we all write
code like this with panels we all like
it
however we with we're not so happy and
when the Cobras too slow and white
columns to store it can be a lot of
reasons for example pandas is now really
designed for large amounts of data as we
all know and it could also be that your
machine doesn't have enough memory to
hold all the data you wanna you won't
look at pandas is mostly a in memory and
library that doesn't really deal with uh
on disk data that well and maybe you're
not utilizing all CPUs pennis is mostly
again a single thread library for the
most part and now these days you you'll
even your laptop has a lot of course and
that is now being utilized so your code
runs too slow so what do we do we have
to try everything we want to make how
code run faster or more a whole momentum
or whole more data so we're gonna try a
few things well use a big machine seems
pretty easy these days and it's how it
actually has a very empowering reason to
do that because that is it has very low
human cost and that's the reason why a
lot of researchers really like to use
big machines these days instead of
looking for another another software
because it's there's no code changes
it's very easy to just just do that
however it is it has a lot of
limitations for example it has to the
same software limit limitation that you
used to have with a smaller machine
handles it's not very good at keeping
copy minimum so pen sometimes makes
unless three copies and that can
become a problem if you have large even
if you have a larger machine that can
become a problem
Pender's a single-threaded like I
mentioned and thank I mean you can make
a code work by using a large larger
machine but it's probably not gonna be
very fast so that's the second thing we
can try is to you can we can try to use
a generic way to distribute our code
here I'm just giving a quick example of
using spark and what I'm basically doing
is assuming I'm assuming I'm analyzing
time series data what I'm doing here is
I'm taking my time range which is we
just 20 years from 2000 to 2012
I split up by year and I send out I said
I sent out the code to the cluster and
have each know to compute only for one
year so that's a pretty straightforward
approach a lot of us use the approach
you know day to day life the advantage
again is it has very well minimum human
cost you still have to make a little bit
of code changes you have probably have
to refactor your compute for year code
to deal with the one year at a time and
do some stitching back but it's not a
huge amount of work you can still use
the majority part of your data analysis
code it's pretty scalable you can show
the data into how many pieces you want
and just just use how many CPUs you want
and this approach also has disadvantages
the first being it only works for
embarrassingly parallel problems which
means it doesn't it's a map only a
computation so if you if you remember
where we are the example show before it
has it actually has a window operation
and the aggregation operation so these
operations are not very straightforward
to paralyze using using this approach
the window operation can have overlaps
and aggregation operation needs data
from multiple shots so it's not very
straightforward how we can just directly
translate the boundary handling can be
tricky like I said when the operation
needs to an it needs to be needs to
handle boundary boundary cases
and now things were using a distributive
framework now we are we are now we open
ourselves to distribute its failures so
the third thing we can try is to
actually use a distributed data frame
library there a cup of out there SPARC
being a very popular one desk is another
very popular one call us as we heard
this morning as there is a new player in
the space all this library there all has
has its own advantage and disadvantage
they're mostly they're mostly pretty
much scalable so they're all designed
for using large amounts of executors or
workers so it's it's entirely scalable
however by using this approach you
basically committed yourself to learn
another API which is a very high human
cost in a lot of cases researchers don't
really like to do that and it's not
obvious which one to use because like I
mentioned they all have different and
advantages and disadvantages combined
with a high learning cost of the high
human cost of learning API not being
able to pick an obvious one becomes even
a bigger problem
and again you're open to distribute
failures because you're using a
distributed library so what can we do
none of these seems very well easy to
pick all of them has problems so what do
we do now so here I want to take a step
back and and and look at what we
actually want to achieve here it's
actually if we look at the code we're
actually pretty happy about the way we
express it it's now that we want to you
know completely rewrite the code to be
something different we kind of just want
to have the same code working but with a
large were the larger data set and run
faster so that brings that that brings
us to our problem the problem is not how
we express the computation we're
actually pretty happy about the code but
we're not happy about how the code is
executed however a lot of the two other
three approaches we talked before
involves code changes or involves how we
rethink about
our computation which is not the problem
here so something seems to be wrong here
the next I want to talk about this
pretty common principle called
separation concern so from a Wikipedia
in computer science separation of
concern is a design principle for
separating computer programs into
distinct sections such that each section
addresses a separate concern how how is
this relevant to to us if we think again
we actually have to - part of the
program here the first part of a program
expressed the computation that's all API
we use for example the rolling the
rolling function the group I function
the aggregation function this is how we
express the computation and the second
part is how we execute a computation you
know in our code example both of these
are appended so panas serves as both the
expression and execution here so here
again we just to readjust to rethink
this
the problem with pendous is not the
expression part but execution part we
want to run the same code but with in a
more scalable way
so can we separate these two things and
maybe that can help us think about what
we can improve improve it and there's
actually a great example of doing this
sequel is a way to express the
computation independent of the execution
if we think about data analysis Seco is
very powerful because you can write you
code once and if it's too slow on this
database you just change it to another
database this happens so much in in the
history of data science we move from
single no sequel databases to
distributor sequel databases we move
from Hadoop to spark with the and that's
all easy and puzzle because because
sequel is a is expression layer
independent of the execution again so
here I wanna I want to think about can
we have something that is very that is
like sequel but for Python data data
analysis I don't ask you to go back to
stop using pandas in using Seco because
that's
kind of crazy but I want you to think
about if you can achieve the same
benefit of sequel but in a Python
library so that brings the motive
motivation of the rest of the talk
here's the outline of the rest of the
talk I'm going to introduce ibis which
is a library designed to address a
problem I raised separation of concern
and that's that's just going to that I
was high level so Ibis is a Python
library for data analysis data analysis
it's an open source library and they
started around 2015 by West makini and
later on it does work but it was worked
on by a lot of top pentameters including
West McKinney Philip cloud and Jeffrey
back and a bunch of other people as well
so Ibis has mostly two components the
first component is the Ibis language and
it is the api that is used to express
the computation and the second part is I
was back-end I have a spike
I respect ends our modules that
translate the expressions into something
that can be executed by different
computation engines so this maps to the
two concept which we talked about
earlier expression and execution and
currently Ibis has a list of backends
supported including panda's back-end
which which uses the pen the pen
decipher we all love PI spark as a new
one which which is actually implemented
by Mia hanji it's a new contribution
recently and there's a couple of other
ones like bickering Impala and and some
GPU databases so Ibis language is
basically two components the first
component is a table API table up here
at the table cat is very similar to a
traditional sequel or pen Pena's kind of
operation you can do projection future
drawing group by sword window
aggregation these are all pretty
standard data
and their host and and it also has
extensions to traditional sequel methods
for example as of joining as a new
addition to either say P I that does
that very useful for analyzing time
series data and the UDF is another
addition to to the library that can that
can be both native Python code with with
the rest of the API and iris expression
is the intermediate representation that
gets translated into different back-end
codes here just a quick example of what
that what that looks like in in actual
code so here I'm just calling a very
simple projection I'm adding a new
column which is the which has some of
the two other columns and here's the
Ibis api to do it and ii I'm showing
Ibis expressions using just the buting
visualization in Ibis here we have a
table and we have a selection on top of
it so it's pretty straightforward and
ibis back and takes the previous
expression and translated into specific
back-end code for for example the same
mutate function will be translating to
as i if you're using pandas backhand and
will translate into with column if
you're using pi spot back in so these
are native back-end code that's specific
to these are native code that's specific
to to the backends so with that I'm
going to get to hanji to talking to more
details okay so the next section is
going to cover more about the Ibis
expression language we talked a
high-level what motivates ibis and why
it's may be useful so this section is
really just going to focus on showing
you how we might express the same
transformation that we saw in pandas
earlier but with ibis so if you recall
our earlier example in pandas li talk
through it and he said the feature is
computed by taking an average of two
columns feature two is computed by doing
a rolling mean over the initial feature
and then we do some sort of aggregation
on our second feature so what would this
look like in Ibis
well let's do let's take it apart line
by line and first cover the basic column
selection and Noora thematic expression
so we have this pinnace code here on the
right and in Ibis it looks pretty
similar with some few differences so
first we would call the table that
mutate API that we introduced earlier
we're creating a new feature and the
rest of it looks pretty similar where we
extract column so you want to be to add
them together and divide by two okay so
what does group by and window decoration
look like well on the right hand side
you see pandas code where we're doing
group by key and we do a rolling average
with a window size of three over our
feature column well in Ibis it's pretty
similar but we construct an Ibis window
and in this case the argument is not
necessarily window size but a preceding
window bound so we're doing current row
and then looking back two rows so it's
equivalent of the rolling three and
we're going to call table dot mutate
again to create a second column called
feature two which is the mean over the
initial feature given our ibis window
and third we had the group by
aggregation in pandas in ibis we call
table group by grouping by the same key
and we call that aggregate calculating
the min and Max of our feature two
columns so this is the overall
translation so what the transformation
would look like expressed in iOS versus
pandas and it's not too different but
there's actually one important
difference that we want to highlight
which is that in iOS these are table
expressions and not actual data frames
so again we want to highlight that
there's a separation of concern we're
separating how we express what we want
to do with executing it so with our ibis
tables there are expressions and not
data frames and in order to actually
execute this on some data I need to have
a real real data in a back-end that I
can actually operate or execute these
transformations on and I'll show you
what I mean by that okay so for this
next section let's look into how we
might execute this on a back-end
so in order to execute any ibex
expression we need to have a back-end
specific Ibis client in this case we
have a PI smart client which you can
just create by calling IVA step PI spark
connect and passing a PI Spock session
if you wanted a panda's client it would
just be Ibis stop panda stop connect or
if you wanted Impala client you might do
August and Paula duck connect passing in
the host and port of Impala server so on
so forth so you kind of get the idea
well to access a table in a certain
back-end you just call client table and
pass in the table name which in this
case is foo what you get in return is a
table expression which we've stored in a
variable called my table so for pi spark
backend for instance I would just take
the PI spark client and call PI spark
client table passing the name foo which
would hopefully would refer to some data
frame and my back-end and save that
expression as my table what I want to
emphasize again is that my table here is
just a table expression it's not an
actual data frame but it refers to a PI
spark table on the backend the name of
that table is foo and we can see here
the schema is that it has three table
columns key v 1m v - keeping a string
column v 1 and v 2 being integer columns
if I actually want to execute this table
expression and get back the data frame I
just call my table execute which
materialized the table expression into a
panda's data frame that I can do other
operations on if I choose to so if you
recall our table transformations earlier
that I showed an Ibis it's the same code
I just wrapped it in a function called
transform that takes in a table
expression and returns a table
expression that has the transformed
results and I can actually apply that
transform on my table and get a result
table which again is just an Ibis table
expression until we execute it and when
I execute it I'll get the result as a
panda's data frame so we kind of get the
gist between the expressions and then
what happens when I execute those
expressions on real data
okay now that we've talked more about
the Ibis language and executing in our
back-end let's focus specifically on the
PI spark backend which we mentioned is
something that we've built over the past
few months so the PI spark back end is
really translating IVIS expressions
which can be represented as expression
trees into PI spark code that we can
execute on PI spark data frames and to
show you a little bit more about how
this works let's go through the same
example and I'll talk through kind of
how we might express this in an
expression tree and how that expression
tree will just translate into PI smart
code so first if we look at the basic
column selection arithmetic expression
that we saw earlier let's focus on this
expression in particular where we're
adding two table columns and dividing by
two
well this ibis expression can be
represented by this expression tree if
we start at the bottom you'll see that
the bottom note is the table node so it
refers to original PI SPARC table we're
extracting two table columns so you want
to v2 we add the two table columns
together and that's the left operand of
the divide operation and on the right
side we have the literal value too well
when we translate this into PI spot code
we actually start at the top of the tree
so we take the division expression and
we have Ivor's translation code so this
is code from the Ibis ibis itself and we
have a method called compiled divide
that takes in a few arguments the first
is T which is a PI sport translator and
the PI spark translator has a translate
method that evaluates an Ibis expression
into the corresponding PI spark object
we'll get back to the sliders to
remember that expr is the Ibis
expression to translate so in this case
the division and scope is a dictionary
that caches results at previously
translated Ibis expressions so for
example if I accessed the table column
v1 multiple times I don't want to have
to compile that multiple times I'll just
look at my scope and find that I've
translated it before and I'll just use
the same result so in
meet of this compile divide code we have
this T translate the left-hand side of
my opera operation and the right-hand
side of my operation and when I call T
dot translate on the left and right
sides which are each themselves Ibis
expressions it will return to me the
result as a PI spar column and the
division just happens by performing a
straightforward PI spar column division
if I look carefully at what the
left-hand side is you'll see that the
left-hand side is another Ibis
expression that's referring to the
addition so addition is another binary
operation and the compiled method for
addition looks very similar the
difference between the division and the
addition is just that we're performing a
PI spot column addition instead of
division well for the compiled ad the
left hand up the left hand of this
operation is a little bit different and
since that it's not another binary
operation but it's actually a table
column access so in this case the table
v1 when we compile a column the code
looks slightly different but essentially
this operation has a field called name
which refers to the table name and when
I translate that
I'll get reference to the PI SPARC data
frame and then the table column when you
compile it is just a simple PI spark
column selection more or less get the
hang of it ok so next let's do something
a little bit more complicated the group
by and window decoration that we saw
earlier I'm not going to show you all
the Ibis translation code because by now
it's mostly just boilerplate
I'll show you directly what it translate
to when we operate in the PI spark back
in so in the PI spark translation of
this the Ibis window just gets
translated into a PI sparks equal window
you can see that has the same group by
our partition by key it has the same
ordering key and the preceding equals to
just translates to the rows between M PI
spark indicating negative 2 so back two
rows of my current row and the end of
that window boundary is the current row
this rolling average over the window
then just uses the native built-in PI
sparks equal function mean a feature
over the give
hi spark window and the table dot mutate
gets translated into a D F dot with
column in PI spark so that's the whole
translation next we had the group by and
the aggregate which looks actually
pretty similar in PI spark so the the
min and Max expressions in Ibis can be
translated into PI spark column
expressions so we use the built in min
and Max PI Spock sequel functions and
the group by an aggregate get translated
into D F group by the key and AG and PI
spark so more or less straightforward
but there are a few more interesting
examples that I want to touch on and
these examples help illustrate why user
might want to use Ibis and not worry
about having to rewrite their code to
run in pandas versus pi spark or
different backends because there are
some subtle tricky differences that we
handle an iris that a user probably
never wants to think about so first is
this rank function so let's say we
wanted to take the view on comm so it
was an integer column if you remember in
our table and just rank it over a given
Ibis window one PI spark there is a
built-in rank function in price of X
equal library where you can pass in you
can call F dot rank over a PI spark
window but to get the same results as
you might get if you were to run this
expression on let's say pin is back-end
you had to handle subtle differences
like this where you're casting the
result to a long and handling some
random off by one error and the only
reason a user would figure this out
would be if they ran their code and
pandas and then translated themselves
and ran it in PI spark and found these
subtle differences if they found them at
all
another example is if you wanted to
perform not any on a boolean column well
in PI spark you'll find that there's no
direct translation and we actually have
to negate the result of the built-in max
function over this boolean column so
it's not really intuitive at all and a
user who is doing something similar in
pandas might have to research or get
familiar with PI spark enough to know
that they could take advantage of this
built-in function in this specific way
okay
so now for the interesting part which is
we showed a lot of code in this
presentation and I'll actually show you
what it looks like to run it in a
notebook okay hopefully this is big
enough for everybody to read so the
first cell here is just importing ibis
and some of the PI spark sequel
utilities that I use and in the second
cell what we have here is some setup
that I did beforehand where I created a
spark session that we'll use to
instantiate an iOS price of our client
and initialize some of the demo data
that we'll use for this okay here's
where it gets interesting so here's the
original pandas example so it's the same
pandas code that was in the presentation
earlier that's computing some feature
columns and then the result is the min
and Max of our second feature feature -
so I just ran this here to show you that
this is the extracted result that we
want for the rest of the demo
so using Ibis we can define this
transform function which is the same one
that we just saw in the slides
that's essentially expressing the same
thing as my pandas code but now that
I've expressed it in Ibis I can actually
execute it on a PI spark back end or
pandas back in pretty easily and
seamlessly without changing any of my
expression code so to execute on a PI
spark backend I'll create a PI spark
client by ibis PI spark connect and
passing in the PI Spock session that I
had reference to earlier
I'll get reference to our table and
create the result by applying the
transform on our table and then I can
compile my result into a PI spark data
frame if I so want to or I can execute
it and also get the expression into a
panda's data frame if I want to work
with a panda's data frame moving forward
and you can see here that the results
are the same as when I executed just in
straight pandas but with the advantage
of expressing our transformation Ibis is
that I can execute seamlessly on Pais
park or pandas without changing any of
our
general transform code so if I want to
then execute it on a pin us back in all
I have to do is create a panda's client
I'll get reference to the same table and
then I can apply the same transformation
on that table execute the result and
hopefully it should be the thing and
they are so thanks Angie with that I
think we're getting close to the end of
the talk so I just want to wrap up and
give give you guys two takeaways
so first takeaway I think it's very
interesting and important to us is we
really want to think this problem in a
way that we can apply the separation of
concern on design point so we will it
will really want a separate expression
execution and that that can bring us a
lot of flexibility into in terms of
which of the component we want to swap
out if we are unhappy about this
particular execution we just change it
to something else without changing the
code so that's the whole point of iris
and the second point as I think is also
interesting here is just as is that
don't limit yourself to only what you
can use today before I've showed you can
use spark desk you can use Korra's today
however this a lot of things going on in
the in the in the in a data analysis
land that you might not be aware of or
them might be available in the future
Aero dataset is a library that West
McKenna has been currently working on
focusing on a single node focusing on
single node a data frame API that that
is designed to be a replacement of
pendous and mouling is a experimental
library out of UC Berkeley to provide
another distributed air from API and the
Q D F and s QT f is a GPU data frame so
all these they're all this fiber that
you're like they're happening and a lot
of people are working on it and when and
it when you wanna use it tomorrow you
don't really want to rewrite all your
code so Ibis as a way to prevent
yourself from having to rewrite your
code in the future that's that's
hopefully interesting to you with that
we're
thanks for coming to the talk and we're
open to questions thank you very much so
my first question the only question is
you've wrote all the code that makes the
connection between between high spice
Park and other distributive packages
libraries so when something new comes
out I you as to Sigma or personally
gonna write the connections to that or
you expect the community to do that so
Ibis is the open source project and to
answer a question most likely will be
the users or the developer of that
particular back-end to to implement the
better backends we implemented high spot
backhands because we use that heavily at
2 Sigma so we are like we are interested
in using that is there any kind of you
know as you do the translation between
the I guess the declaration and the
backend execution is there any
optimization that happens so like you
know you're obviously going for
distributed data frames like is it just
simply you're rewriting that declaration
in sequel or do you ever try to break up
the sequel to a separate execution
module sort of parallel yeah that's a
very good question and our current
approach is not to do any optimization
and defer to the backend because I think
the backend does a better job of
executing it and optimization is a
property of the execution so if we do
some optimization there might not be
useful or or you even good that did
answer question
I think also at the same time so when
we're translating different back ends I
think regardless of what backhand it is
you do have to be smart about how you
translate it because there are many
different ways that you can express the
same thing so for pi sparks you PI spark
back and in particular we might choose
to use let's say pandas UDF's / built-in
spark UDF's because that's more
efficient in many cases since it's
vectorized so well that was my second
question actually is have you found any
practical experience with a migration
that would show whether or not you know
the Ibis version of the code would run
better than a person trying to do the
migration right so like if I were using
a panda's data frame one day and I
decided to rewrite it in bigquery right
like I'm curious about whether or not
people would do a better job than the
framework you have any metrics or data
or anecdotal stories yeah we can't don't
emotionally so one of the challenges of
converting pandas to Pais barcode is not
so much the difference in syntax but the
the whole paradigm around like lazy
transformations and actions and how you
know if you're not aware of it you can
do a group by and like a whole bunch of
transformations and then you do a count
right before you do a write it actually
does that shuffle twice right which of
course is very suboptimal because you're
doing it twice so it does Ibis address
that at all or cuz like you showed it in
a notebook right so like it's very easy
to think that if you don't have to
change the syntax very much that it runs
the same way that like you actually get
a full data object every time you
instead of a query plan I mean yeah I
think that's a very good question I
think one sort of design principle of
Ibis is it's lazy executed and the
reason for that is is really without
without that design principle it's
really hard to separate these two
concerns so it is is this kind of a gap
between pandas users because pandas
users are used to the your execution
mode and that that's just something I
think going forward
people have to uh I guess get used to we
have time for one more - one or two more
questions
any other questions thanks that's a very
interesting project I noticed in your
example which I got is a really
simplified example it seems like all of
the work Python is doing is just helping
you construct this abstract syntax tree
for your your ibis expression and you're
not really taking advantage of it being
in Python until you get the data back
out so I'm wondering when people use it
for larger projects how much
back-and-forth is there between actually
using Python to do processing and doing
all the processing in Ibis so what do
you mean by doing the processing in
Python I'm sorry so in your example all
of the function calls in Python are just
returning new ibis notes right like
there's no actual computation happening
in Python okay so in a sense you could
have just written your own ibis language
that compiles directly to your Ibis
syntax tree right
you're not getting anything out of it
being in Python does that make sense
what everybody writing all I was saying
maybe I should take it up with you yeah
yeah sorry yeah that's absolutely all
right
thank you very much everyone have a good
day
[Applause]